there is a conservative a British
politician who rung a Greenpeace
activists neck when she interrupted a
speech in the United Kingdom a few days
ago and I'm gonna set this up for you
mark field is a member of parliament or
an MP as they are known in the United
Kingdom he's 54 years old he's a member
of the Conservative Party in the UK also
known as the Tories and a few days ago
Chancellor Philip Hammond was giving a
speech about brexit at what's called the
bankers and merchants dinner
Greenpeace Greenpeace is the climate
activist organization they sent 40
volunteers to the to this event to try
to interfere with the speech and get
attention for climate change one woman
was walking around there as part of this
protest and Mark fields got up and
grabbed her and pushed her and then
wrung her neck some might almost call it
strangling from behind although I don't
know that that's the right term in this
particular case and there is video so
immediately the question is is this
treatment too rough for someone that
seems to be one of 40 peaceful
protesters some have argued she could
have had a gun
hard to imagine from the dress she was
wearing that she had a gun not to
mention both of her hands were full of
items which would make it quite
difficult to even get a gun out of her
purse if that's what she had and where
she had it Fields is saying his reaction
was quote instinctive given the
circumstances and Fields has since
apologized to the woman there are other
MPs calling for this guy to go Labour MP
Tanya Antonio at sea says quote no one
who reacts like this to a peaceful
protest should be sitting in our
Parliament Liberal Democrat MP chuka
Emunah says that the actions are totally
unacceptable
former Tory MP Sarah Wollaston says it
was quote absolutely shameful a male MP
marching a woman out of a room by her
neck Labour Minister Don Butler tweeted
this as horrific mark field must
immediately be suspended or sacked
bottom line a woman in a ball gown with
high heels holding a cell phone in a
small purse is not the threat that
instinctively was apparently what went
to mark
mind here it's extremely difficult to
buy that now some people are making this
a man versus woman issue saying oh
you're only upset because the protestor
was a woman but it would have been
totally fine if the protestor had been a
man there is no question that gender is
a factor here I would argue it's a
reasonable factor but beyond that a
sitting MP putting his hands on a member
of the public's throat is now what we're
defending I got an email from a viewer
saying the way this guy reacted his
entire posture his entire demeanor
during this is of a classic domestic
abuser I would not argue that this guy
is a domestic abuser absent evidence
that he is a domestic of you abuser what
I do believe is that this is a level of
aggression that did come naturally to me
to him in the moment and I can also tell
you that in the United States far less
aggressive physical attacks than this
often lead to people being charged with
battery so I want to hear from you what
do you think about this if you've been
listening to the podcast a radio show
and you you didn't see the video that we
just played for a video audience find
the video online and let me know what
you think of it